yeah hello and welcome to this video I'd
get someone to talk here how a second
yes Rex plays g5 that's a refreshingly
generous so I'm playing elegance now
what that said to the NI again reverse
and i just have the jeep on it's nicer
it just gave me the jeep on so on you
can take here right it's no particular
reason not to do it the jeep one missing
cannot be some kind of advantage okay so
can you play this here right
yeah what hotel then how did that work
anyway I'm like you go here and there's
this Knight g4 move that is somewhat
irritating what are you doing then Queen
d2 may be quite remember that will
probably have to do again 94 I cannot
take it 24 wins then but Queen d2 is I
think correct covering d4 and preparing
a 23 he doesn't even do it and just goes
back okay so five or c3 fc3s I I think a
simple and good move it's a little bit
slow 93 to 95 looks tempting but it
cannot be bad here maybe just this one
kind of gain the temple because it
doesn't want to trade queens I guess and
now we should be five maybe Pinder's now
complete development
it's probably going to try to play as
five that's actually actually quite
active for him so maybe I'll try to
trade Queens if he takes on the H file
also opens for my rook so let's see f5
certainly a move and night XD for those
kind of things might be might be on yeah
I think I'll just drop the bishop back
here Chuck g8 maybe yeah I think I just
do this
just cover the pawn Andrew have one next
so here I can go e5 or just let him take
d5 no this half looks wrong yeah let's
just get everything into the game
Wow so let's just get the protected paso
that's also easy to play now because he
has absolutely no counter play that's
where I said why I said Wow because it
just looks very one-sided now yeah I'm
pretty sure why had a very good position
anyway but this is now it's fairly easy
just turn probably winning the H poem or
the F palm or both at the f1
there's no need to to rush things here
check actually go to be 8
yeah actually true f5 comes Jeff
yeah 3 pounds by now my as a light
squared location so takes a moment to
break down so how to do that time
morning so not that simple actually
tick he is going to grab this so now i'm
going to go to e5 no it isn't allow its
edge so i have to do it a little bit
differently things how to do it okay
then left go wire before I thought I
have something some other way it
probably not black for fits on time yeah
g55 is really really lucky just just
something that you take and then yes
really this is really just an elegance
defense with with the jeep on missing
and this is just just a pawn for nothing
g porn is small uninformed ready and now
we we just had a gap reversed Vienna or
something and it's alignments it's bad
anyway so get you hired probably I could
have punished this a bit more
aggressively this is a funny move
threatening made and I cannot take it
okay but this is goodness covers
everything yeah probably if I've is more
aggressive c3 is not not that powerful
words it makes my my nights more passive
but
yeah ultimately interes material down
and this makes it very easy okay I could
have taken at five even worse this is
just a simple very simple way to play
just pick up porn after all a second
[Music]
yeah going into the ndn game that I went
into wasn't was it all that clever we
acted took to quite a while to win and
so stupid yeah what am I doing here just
King do form was a plate this plate is
quite badly i mean it is always going to
win but it's just not the quickest way
to do it yeah now I'm becoming coming
around with with the king yeah a g5 not
on Knight f3 against her yeah well
actually it is never really playable
against any move but even see 45 is
pretty bad but that you at least don't
lose immediately ok guys thanks for
watching